I have made the worst mistake ever made
in Minecraft do you hear me someone will
have to pay for this I don't know whose
fault that is I can't believe I did this
here get a look at me
it was in my fault here again it wasn't
my fault oh he doesn't even want to talk
to me anymore
Sven I'm so sorry man
how did I make this mistake Oh God
oh you grew up oh he grew up okay how do
I say this basically I forgot who this
dog was so I accidentally made him braid
with Sven look at him he's traumatized
he's shaking he's been shaking for hours
I made sense okay I can't even say it
I'm a friend freaky son ah
you're a child of Satan you're not
supposed to live what you're an Oracle
oh my god it's like the Swedish folklore
you can tell the future no I will have
to do it
I'm sorry deep there's no other way
what's that Swayne won't even talk
because of you all right
I'm gonna I need to figure out how to
deal with you because you can't leave
but I also can't I can't just get rid of
a dog what do i do what do i do I need
help
don't look at me like that you have to
die I'm sorry I'm sorry I don't make the
rules you have to die now go in there
come here how do I get rid of him I
guess I can push him into the lava yeah
I guess that makes sense I just follow
me just follow me all right
trust me this is not easy for me there
all right
it's fun it's I know it's hot I'm just
gonna take you to the mountain of doom
what's the mountain of doom don't worry
about it it's a nice place it's where
you live forever yeah yeah that's right
you'll live forever in the mountain of
doom you want to go back to your your
two dads that's not that's not gonna
happen
we're gonna go to mount they don't worry
about it it's gonna be great what's that
it's it's really hot in your sweaty dogs
don't sweat stop it the demon Oracle
what's that you love me so much and you
want to go to mountain of doom shut up
shut up okay here it is here at this and
then we we just dig I think yeah yeah
yeah here it goes oh yeah you have to go
you have to go okay some doggy land is
down there trust me it's gonna be epic
how do I make him jump because I'm not
gonna push it
that would be inhumane go go take the
chicken take the chicken oh my god I
don't care if you love me please go
please go please don't make this harder
than it is I can't do it Kenny
there's no way I can't do it what do I
do
someone has to pay for this follow me oh
my god you stinky all right how about
this
stay there until I figure out what to do
with you damn it why is minecraft so
complicated this needs to be so easy you
build stuff you discover stuff and
that's it not dealing with demon childs
how did we get here I don't want to be
here don't worry they know better el
bair i was quiet quiet everyone quiet
I'm stressed out I don't know how to
deal with this I don't know how to deal
with this I must consult Council of
Watership council water shape how could
you let this happen
[Music]
look at me
this is sorry plan all along I'm
starting to think Council of authorship
isn't so nice after mark my word the
council about the Sheep you will regret
this I know what I must do something I
never looks when still shaking the Sun
is completely out of it he's beyond
recovery as soon as he found out that he
put pee pee in I don't even want to say
it there's only one thing to do
there's realistically only one thing to
do I can't believe the sin we're gonna
blow up Church of what their sheep well
make this oh okay he's okay I think it's
yes I think stop it
I'm completely out of rockets but I
built something on my spare time before
I realized don't tell anyone
if the news gets out about Sven putting
PP it will destroy him all right don't
tell anyone don't tell anyone this
happened I built this thing look at it
it's beautiful it's supposed to be a
creeper farm it took a long time all
right I don't even know why I'm spending
time building stuff in this game anymore
it's completely pointless but I need
paper okay I never I never tried it I
wonder how much 37 and I'll take it all
right how do I make it again I forgot
yes okay cool
so now we can flame okay epic I'm not
enjoying this flight the word spent all
right here we go all right we have to
line up this shot perfectly I'm gonna
blow it ups men I'll make you proud I'll
make you proud spend I can't believe it
we had so many memories oh my god I
think Oh Council of sheep
give me guidance of what to do make the
Thunder rain please please I beg you
cancel of what the shoes oh my god what
their sheep answered the prayer I never
thought in a million years that I'd been
doing this you know some people would
blame it on me and say it's my bad
memory and it's my own fault no no this
is nothing to do with me it's all
counselled weather let's see if I know
how to build this okay yeah I know how
to build this we're gonna build a cannon
I think I remember how to build a cannon
I am not entirely sure we'll see how
this goes basically I'm missing
something aren't I
I'm missing water god dang it I will fly
away I'm sure I have some Oh God I'm
alive I'm alive
I gotta have a bucket right yeah yeah
yeah I have buckets in my neatly
organized cool I don't have a bucket I
don't even know where my - dang it all
right I'll find I'll find some steel you
can't be that hard
oh wait I know how I know how I have
this oh I feel like that's a bad idea
I shouldn't be doing this hi yes okay
now just fly out this might look cool
actually like a little Batman thing yeah
that was definitely a Batman thing right
all right and we fly in it's pretty dope
you can't fly into your house how many
places can you say you can do that I
have to smelt iron and stuff I forgot
how to play Minecraft so maybe it's my
fault after all while I do that I'm
gonna get some food
look at that keyboard arrow I still have
it I always carry him with me even him
even he is looking at me in shame I need
to say hi to everything why do you be
quiet I have had it up to here with you
okay let me get spend spend spend I know
you don't want to I don't know I know
you don't want to move I'll move for you
don't worry come here I know you're
traumatized but I need you to see this
I can't even imagine well how you feel
then I literally can't even imagine all
right Syd there's one and we place that
there
it's just correct no it isn't if my
calculations are correct we should now
be able to blow up oh god oh my god Sven
we're blowing up I can't even look
that's not what I wanted to do it's
working it's working it's working
hey dang it
hold up one space all right here we go
see it date Smith D oh my god he's
double traumatized now what are they
wrong all right come here spend oh my
god it looks like he's got a little
sailor hat that's so cute meat for good
luck
they must have put a cutter turns
tiresome just blow up
just blow up it should work it's working
oh it's blowing up wrong way okay
it's work it works in why don't I just
put a button said I don't I'm not very
smart Sven okay okay dead you will all
dead
yes lucky lucky another one another back
swing another batch bullseye
did you see that that's right Sven they
will pay it just bounced up the meatball
what's that saying I shouldn't hurt them
that's bull you're under they put you in
there a spell or something same Wow
we're gonna have to do this the
old-fashioned way this is how we did it
back in my day in Switzerland oh look at
you look at you bear bear bear
you will not bear it so much anymore
will you hold on let me just let me just
place this here oh it's this new
wallpaper yeah
wallpaper it's just new wallpaper let me
just let me just play some more of that
sweet no not like this yeah
ah okay how are they alive you're not to
put yeah dang it all right you try to
stop me you will never stop me yeah I
did water forgot the water doesn't
explode maybe guy I got three more I got
to make them count this is four spins
Alabama Sun how do I lit it can I lit it
with a button hit the button Oh God
run run run it's gonna blow you might
die run hurry you might die
are you serious it didn't blow up
anymore I really was expecting like a
big explosion not just oh god okay no I
forgot I had keep inventory on I'm sorry
that's kind of cheating they're gone
Jake sighs oh my god
it's over it's over Council of what
there she it's no more
they were like father to me all this
time I never realized just what a great
father figure there were for me be quiet
I did it's men I did it for you
because I love you what's that you
wanted me to bring back your son Sven
you don't understand what's that I
should bring him back otherwise you
won't be friends with me anymore
but spent you don't understand it's okay
I'll get him back oh god I can't believe
I'm bringing back the son of Satan
what's that you want me to name him I'm
not gonna name something so demonic
don't even be close to each other you
two you are not supposed to be close to
each other
you filthy you're dirty
fine I'll go back and get him I can't
believe this
I literally what are you doing get out
of here oh god I don't even know will he
still be there where did I leave him I
forgot all the mountain of do I have to
hurry
oh god I regret everything Jesus does it
again ah son of [ __ ] you're still here I
don't have a name for you come here
follow me and you get to live I guess no
[Music]
just come with me stinky you should be
damn lucky Sven is such a good person
because if it was with me I would make a
different story what am I saying
right where did he go pretty go hey no
stop it stop it I knew it he belongs in
hell stop defending him all right fine
you'd live here this is your home
okay until you've proven that you're
good however I will I will name you
because the subreddit has decided that
you shall be named Alabama I am
disgusted Alabama iw Alabama urug the
hell dog the guardian of this realm
you stay here okay I don't trust you I
don't trust you at all
you shouldn't exist there's no reason
for you to live there understand that
you shouldn't live you shouldn't be here
no one likes you
no one you smell not good you probably
don't have many friends you were an
accident do you understand that an
accident
enjoy okay Sam I did what you said I'm
just gonna dig deep and put him the heck
out of her use your sight don't ever
don't you guys ever stop it stop that
stop it you've belong over here you can
stay with the arrogance Merrigan I can't
believe this
alright how many maybe do we got well we
got one well maybe I need to stay around
here to get more alright hopefully we
can keep moving past this and no one
will know that this ever happened what
what's that smell did not have sex with
his son stop it
I have to pray to tower of Ikea I can't
do this anymore it's gone to fun I'm
ending this episode here I'm shocked I'm
disgusted
and I'm ending it now smash like and see
you gamers next time hey though you know
what's big peepees do they play
PewDiePie's pixel ings of course pixel
ings is a creature collecting game I'm
the primary shareholder over a bazillion
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time PewDiePie
pixel aims it's awesome deal with it
build with it
[Music]